solve for x and we have x times x minus
5 times 2x plus 3 is equal to
0. now let's think about this for a
second if we have the product of a bunch
of numbers if we have the product of a
and b and c and i told you that the
product is equal to zero what do we know
about either a or b or c
well this tells us at least one of these
numbers has to be equal to zero the only
way to get the product of numbers being
equal to zero is if at least one of
these numbers are equal to zero so this
means that a is equal to zero or
b is equal to zero
or
or c is equal to 0. it's not just the
case if you had 3 if i had a b c d equal
to 0 that means one of those numbers
could be equal to 0 at least one of them
has to be equal to 0. all of them could
be 0 or 1 could be 0 and the other 2
could be non-zero so let's apply the
same principle here we have the product
of two three expressions we have that
expression there we have that expression
there and that expression there the
product is equal to zero so that tells
us that either x is equal to 0
or
or x minus 5 is equal to 0
x minus 5 is equal to 0 or
or
2x
plus 3 is equal to zero sometimes that's
called the principle of zero products
but they're just saying look if i take
the product of a bunch of things and
they equal zero at least one of those
things need to be equal to zero so
that's all we're applying here so we've
actually already found one solution x
could be equal to zero to find the other
solutions let's solve these equations so
if x minus five is zero if you add five
to both sides of that equation
we get x is equal to five so that is our
second solution x could be equal to five
and then finally over here if we solve
two x plus three is equal to zero we can
subtract three from both sides and we
get 2x is equal to negative 3
and then we can divide both sides by 2
and we get x is equal to negative
negative 3 halves and we have our three
solutions and we could check them we
could check them if you put x is equal
to zero into this first thing what's
going to happen you're going to have
let's let's check this one right over
here you're going to have 0 times
0 minus 5 which is negative 5
times
two times zero zero plus three times
three now clearly this is equal to zero
i didn't even have to evaluate these two
things i put a had a zero here zero
times anything else is going to be equal
to zero
so that works
could try this guy out so if x is equal
to 5 you're going to have
5
times 5 minus 5 which is 0 and that
makes sense because we got the solution
by assuming that maybe the second term
was 0 and then times 2 times 5 plus 3 is
13. we don't even have to look at the
other ones because we know that middle
term is 0. so clearly this whole thing
is going to simplify to 0. and the last
one and you almost don't have to work it
out because you know that it's when you
evaluate x at negative when x is
negative three halves it's going to make
this last term zero and when this last
term is zero doesn't matter what these
first two terms are the whole thing is
going to be zero well let's just do it
just for fun so if you put that x in
you're going to get negative three let
me do that same magenta color you're
going to have what happened to my
magenta it feels like my magenta
disappeared i'll do it in purple you're
going to have negative 3 halves that's
hard to read i'll do it in green
negative 3 halves
times negative three halves minus five
times two times negative three halves is
negative three
plus three
now that is clearly equal to zero i
don't even have to evaluate this i have
a bunch of stuff times zero it's clearly
going to be equal to zero so all three
of our solutions work